[Musica]
abbiamo un'opportunità
abbiamo una grande opportunità
abbiamo l'opportunità di aumentare
le difese immunitarie dei nostri giovani
dei nostri figli
contro il disagio in comportamenti a
rischio
abbiamo l'opportunità di aumentare il
loro benessere
a parma stiamo costruendo abbiamo
costruito un progetto multi componente
che vuole che tutti noi istituzioni
imprese università scuola genitori
insegnanti ragazzi
diventiamo comunità educante
un progetto che abbiamo voluto chiamare
web è di rete educante
nel mondo ci sono progetti di
prevenzione che hanno dato ottimi
risultati nel tempo
noi ne abbiamo preso in considerazione
tre per le varie fasce
li abbiamo analizzati per questo che il
progetto carta ma che potrà essere poi
traslata in qualsiasi realtà del
territorio italiano ma partiamo
dall'inizio
che cos'è il disagio
il disagio è una condizione situazione
incomoda spiacevole piena di stenti
provare mancanza di ciò che è necessario
e la prevenzione la prevenzione un atto
un comportamento inteso ad anticipare un
evento dannoso
il primo progetto che abbiamo
considerato nello stream di partnership
progetto di prevenzione per giovani
donne in gravidanza è in difficoltà
consistente in viste quindicinali
durante la gravidanza i primi due anni
di vita dei bambini primi due anni di
vita
il follow up effettuato dopo 18 anni
ha dimostrato migliori competenze
cognitive migliori abilità matematiche
miglior abilità linguistiche
molti dei bambini che hanno partecipato
nei primi due anni di vita al progetto
si sono diplomati a differenza dei
bambini del gruppo di controllo il
progetto è stato fatto in 42 nazioni in
42 stati degli stati uniti d'america ha
coinvolto 280 mila famiglie e pensate un
po si sono risparmiati 5.7 dollari per
ogni dollaro speso
quindi fare prevenzione conviene
secondo progetto
montreal canada montreal dogi tudin
altec sperimentalista di progetto di
prevenzione per bambini fra i 7 e 9 anni
iperattivi e per i loro genitori
per aumentare le abilità pro sociali e
di autocontrollo
il follow up effettuato quando i bambini
hanno compiuto fra gli 11 ei 12 anni ha
dimostrato che un 20 per cento continua
ad avere problemi di autocontrollo
contro il 44 per cento del gruppo di
controllo
il 30 per cento
aveva buone reda silico i pari a
differenza del 19 per cento del gruppo
di controllo terzo esempio per l'itunes
modelli islandese progetto multi
componente dal quale abbiamo rubato
tutto il possibile nato nel 1998 e che
vede coinvolte le istituzioni la scuola
all'università i giovani gli insegnanti
i genitori e le associazioni culturali e
sportive
volendo a ridurre i fattori di rischio
aumentando quelli di protezione
si è partiti da analisi dei bisogni che
fondamentale si è monitorato
costantemente e validato
scientificamente ogni passaggio del
progetto e sia istituirli schon
costantemente i risultati ai cittadini
che in questo modo si sentono parte
integrante del progetto
risultati dopo tre anni di
implementazione la percentuale di
giovani fra i 15 e 16 anni dediti al
cosiddetto binge drinking il bere in
maniera smodata al solo fine di
ubriacarsi e diminuito direi crollato
del 60 per cento lo stesso dicasi per il
consumo di cannabis e per l'uso
quotidiano di tabacco se guardate il
grafico dopo il primo anno c'è stato un
aumento dell'uso
dopo tre anni minimo 60 per cento dati
2020 siamo quasi a zero con queste
partite
cosa ci dicono anche queste cose beh la
prima cosa che ci dicono è che un
progetto di prevenzione
previene il disagio i comportamenti a
rischio
non la droga non di bullismo non la
violenza ma il disagio i comportamenti a
rischio che possono portare
alla droga
al bullismo tutte cose che possono
diventare croniche che è molto difficile
risolvere la seconda cosa quando
comincia un progetto di prevenzione e
due persone adulte che decidono di avere
un bambino
hanno un progetto di genitorialità che
possiamo considerare un progetto di
prevenzione la produzione comincia
quando due adulti decidono di avere un
bambino
il terzo fattore fondamentale la
prevenzione non è e non può essere
episodica la prevenzione va
costantemente monitorata
scientificamente validate e deve essere
permanente
scusate se mi ripeto ma la prevenzione
deve essere permanente non ci sogneremmo
mai di fare prevenzione sanitaria per un
anno dopodiché sapendo che le cose sta
andando abbastanza bene piantiamo di
tutto la stessa cosa vale per la
prevenzione
oggi la scienza ci fornisce strumenti
per migliorare il benessere dei nostri
giovani e soprattutto per fare in modo
che non si mettono nei guai questione di
pandemia ma non solo hanno aumentato sia
il disagio il disagio giovanile che i
comportamenti a rischio è sempre troppo
alta la percentuale di giovani che
abbandona il percorso scolastico prima
del tempo i dati istat parlano del 15
per cento di chi si iscrive in prima
elementare che non arriva a completare
l'obbligo scolastico 16 anni è aumentato
il numero di giovani che si chiudono in
casa perché non si sentono adeguati alle
sfide del quotidiano il cosiddetto
fenomeni che komori le associazioni che
se ne occupano l'eas parla di numeri che
vanno fra i 100 ei 120 mila
sono aumentate le dipendenze perché
oltre a quelle la sostanza quelli che
conosciamo tutte classiche e dai co ci
sono quelle comportamentali da gaming da
gioco d'azzardo da internet ed è
aumentato tantissimo il numero di
giovani che con piatti di auto lisi
gli studi parlano del 25 per cento di
giovani tra gli 11 e 16 anni che si
taglia per lenire il male di vivere
uno su quattro è nella maggior parte
delle occasioni neanche ce ne accorgiamo
sono ancora troppi anche i giovani i
minori autori di reato i dati 2017 gli
ultimi disponibili parlano di oltre 32
mila minori autori del reato
ma sono partito da parma e voglio
tornare a parma tra che con un gruppo di
rappresentanti del comune
dell'università della scuola
dell'associazionismo
e della sanità ci siamo seduti a un
tavolo per comprendere come portare a
parlarne un progetto multi componente
che ci possa vedere tutti come linee tu
ca nun te tutti in relazione
perché oggi che cosa succede e oggi si
fanno tanti progetti di prevenzione
contro il fumo contro la droga contro il
bullismo contro la violenza per il
vivere sano e molto spesso questi
progetti hanno come centro motore la
scuola anche giustamente se torniamo
alle percentuali di abbandono scolastico
se abbassassimo la percentuale di
abbandono scolastico si abbasserebbe
anche la percentuale di bulli piuttosto
che di violenti o di futuri dipendenti
da sostanze
ma troppo spesso la scuola ed è legata
al risultato educativo non veniamo
coinvolti in prima persona
quindi cosa possiamo fare vi faccio un
esempio prendiamo un bambino lo
chiameremo luca che mentre sta facendo
un progetto multi componente che gli dà
competenze di dita spirito critico
creatività empatia a scuola
supporta anche gli insegnanti nel modo
migliore per dare queste competenze di
vita luca ma li supporta anche nel
comprendere quali sono i segnali di
disagio
che magari gli insegnanti vedono anche
tutti i giorni ma che fanno fatica a
vedere quella giustamente perché
ricordiamocelo gli insegnanti non sono
dei tuttologi oggi gli insegnanti hanno
una delega educativa enorme ma non
possono sapere tutto poi luca torna a
casa e guarda un po i suoi genitori
seguono lo stesso percorso educativo di
luca dal punto di vista chiaramente i
genitori supportano luca nel far
crescere queste competenze e già qui
abbiamo fatto un bel passo in avanti
scuola genitori
poi luca che un bravo bambino fa i suoi
dei compiti poi va da allenamento dove
anche il suo allenatore segue questo
percorso condivide queste competenze e
cerca di migliorare le qualità di luca
incentivando la star bene con i suoi
pari per esempio
adesso invece pensiamo sempre a luca che
fa un bel progetto di prevenzione a
scuola
poi torna a casa dove vorrebbe
condividere coi genitori quello che sta
facendo gli piace poi fra l'altro anche
durante l'ora di matematica quindi
meglio di così
ma come sempre ci accade spesso ci
accade quando torniamo soprattutto in
quella cosiddetta pausa pranzo
vuoi lamela telefonata il pensiero alla
rai non è che c'è nel pomeriggio allora
luca si mette a giocare questo
telefonino cosa che sempre accade e noi
gli facciamo notare che la deve smettere
di stare attaccato al telefonino con il
nostro telefonino in mano e luca fa
capire fa fatica a capire questo poi
luca che comunque un bravo bambino e fa
i suoi dei compiti vada allenamento e il
suo allenatore gli fa notare
che siccome non è molto bravo non verrà
convocato per le partite tutt'al più se
non c'è il numero potrà stare in
panchina
pensate che le competenze che la scuola
cerca di dare a luca
verranno valorizzate in un ambiente
sociale che non le riconosce io credo
che sia faticoso
questa è la differenza sostanziale fra
un progetto multi componente è una serie
di progetti anche vallina fatti in
maniera staccata separata e non nello
stesso momento che non coinvolgono tutti
gli adulti significativi perché un
progetto multi componente vuole che
tutti gli adulti significativi
abbiano la possibilità di formarsi e si
formino per il benessere loro dei nostri
giovani e della comunità
a proposito della complessità di un
progetto multi componente è stato
anticipato la parte che riguarda i
genitori l'abbiamo fatta insieme all'onu
mica bau bau micio micio l'invio siamo
riusciti a farci dare d'alloro il loro
progetto dedicato alle famiglie si
chiama famiglia united che cerca di dare
degli strumenti per le sfide quotidiane
con i propri figli e adatto ai genitori
fra gli 8 ei 15 anni
strumenti per giocare magari tempo di
qualità quei dieci minuti che abbiamo
durante le nostre giornate piene di
impegni o come porsi quando fanno
opposizione o quanto fanno i capricci o
quando c'è qualche proprio una scuola in
questo modo si aumenta il benessere
della famiglia perché si aumenta il
benessere dei genitori che hanno
maggiore consapevolezza per su come
guidare i figli ad avere quelle
competenze di vita che vi serviranno ad
adulti ma soprattutto li terranno
lontano dai guai
ecco quindi cosa possiamo fare
ognuno di noi è padre madre fratello
nonno non allenatore insegnante ognuno
di noi può essere un pezzo fondamentale
del territorio e avere l'umiltà di
pensare che possiamo migliorarci come
educatori perché questo siamo mettersi
in rete con gli altri genitori con la
scuola
smetterla di pensare magari che siccome
i nostri genitori ci hanno educato in un
certo modo quello è sicuramente il modo
giusto
farsi delle domande la prima delle quali
potrebbe essere perché non posso
migliorarmi
a questo proposito il progetto dedicato
anche questo è stato anticipato ai più
piccoli che si chiama appunto sole è
basato essenzialmente sul tentativo di
rispondere a grandi domande ve ne faccio
una a titolo esemplificativo come faccio
a sapere quando ha ragione
il tentativo di rispondere a queste
grandi domande perché questa è una
grande domanda in piccoli gruppi in
autonomia con il supporto di adulti
esperti e autorevoli ha visto crescere
allo spirito critico l'empatia la
creatività el umiltà intellettuale
quest'ultima e predittiva del benessere
futuro più del quoziente intellettivo
se avremo l'umiltà di smettere di
pensare di sapere tutto cosa complicata
in un periodo nel quale basta googlare
per credere di aver capito tutto su
qualsiasi argomento o di affidarsi alla
tradizione familiare o al libero che ha
consigliato mio cugino di solito con 3g
quadrati con l'ho letto su un qualsiasi
sito per esempio
www.educazioneacquatica.it arena esiste
allora faremo un gran favore ai nostri
giovani ai nostri figli e lo stesso vale
per il tessuto produttivo locale perché
le competenze di vita che avranno i
nostri giovani attraverso questi
progetti li renderanno degli adulti in
grado di lavorare in gruppo di avera
creatività spirito critico di saper
ascoltare cosa molto complicata oggi mi
viene da pensare che se il tessuto
produttivo locale ci supporterà in
questo progetto si farà un favore
allora la vogliamo cogliere
quest'opportunità
vogliamo essere educatori quali siamo
consapevolmente o meno
vogliamo coinvolgere le istituzioni
perché il progetto possa partire in
tutta la sua complessità e avete visto i
risultati all'estero vogliamo
coinvolgere il tessuto produttivo perché
possa essere di ampio respiro
possibilmente permanente ci vogliamo
credere o no ci possiamo crederlo
[Applauso]